[موسيقى]
جبوره مغترب في اوروبا لسانه عربي لكن
قلبه اسرائيلي يعبر عن ذلك بكل فخر ودون
خجل جاره ناصر مسلم عربي مناصر للحق اينما
كان بدءا بفلسطين
يؤكد ذلك في فكره وقوله
والعمل التقيا هذا الاسبوع فقال جبوره
لاحظ يا ناصر كيف ان ارهابيي حماس دمروا
غزه بعد اجبارهم اسرائيل على ممارسه حقها
في الرد رد عليه ناصر لكن الاحتلال يرد
بقتل الاطفال والنساء نسال الله وحده ان
يحميهم وان يكتب النصر
للمقاومه قال جبوره هذا الذي تفلحون فيه
تشجعون الفلسطينيين على الموت وانتم
مرتاحون في بيوتكم فعاجله ناصر برد من
عيار 10 و5 انت تعلم انني وملياري مسلم
ممنوعون من الوصول الى غزه لكن وصولك الى
كيان اسرائيل متاح فلماذا تناصر حبيبتك
اسرائيل عن بعد يا جبوره الى العناوين
كتائب القسام لا تقلي البيض بل تشوي
المركا ضابط اسرائيلي جنازه عسكريه كل خمس
دقائق مستشرق يهودي نقاتل للدنيا ويقاتلون
لاجل الله خ الله حاخام بارز يطالب بضم
سيناء والنيل لاسرائيل
خبير عسكري فرنسي طوفان الاقصى بدايه
النهايه جيش الاحتلال المذعور في غزه يعدم
اسراه
ميدانيا الفاتيكان يصف قتل اسرائيل
مسيحيتين في غزه
بالارهاب حمله بطاقات الفي اي بي
الاسرائيليه يريدون مقاضاه شهداء فلس
وسامر ابو دقه شهيدا والصوره لا
[موسيقى]
تغيب مرحبا هبط مستوى جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الى البيض الحاضر بقوه في
بياناته فقد حاول التندر وقال ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه فقدت قوتها العسكريه ولن تتمكن
من قلي بيضه رغم ما انه ثبت في ساحات
الوغا ان جنود اسرائيل قدموا بدون بيضات
ليقل
الفلسطينيون وغزه محاصره ولا تدخلها
البضائع والاغذيه فردت حركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه لا وقت لدينا لقلي البيض
فمقاومة من احتفاء جيش الاحتلال بعثوره
على نفق كبير لكنه بدا ككم يستعمل
المناديل الورقيه المستعمله وهذا غير صحي
كتائب القسام كشفت ان هذا النفق الضخم
القريبه من غلاف غزه استخدمته لمره واحده
واخيره من اجل تنفيذ طوفان الاقصى عساكم
من عواده يقولون ويعلقون على جهر وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يواف جلن بالتعب في
غزه حماس منظمه ارهابيه هيات نفسها على
مدى عقود من الزمن لمحاربه اسرائيل وقد
جهزوا بنيه تحتيه فوق الارض وتحتها وليس
من السهل تدمير ذلك سيتطلب فتره طويله من
الزمن المحلل السياسي الاسرائيلي امنون
ابراموفيتش سائم الشعارات الطنانه في
الاعلام العبري ودعاه لان يرى جيدا كيف ان
غزه التحت لم يمسسها ضرر رغم كل
الانتصارات على الاطفال والنساء والبطون
في غزه الفوقه الصور تبدو في الاعلام
دائما اكثر تفاؤلا نحن بعيدون جدا من
الحسم غزه السفليه اغلبها سالمه في خان
يونس مسسنا في الغلاف وحسب وليس بمخيمات
الوسط وهناك جيوب مقاومه قاسيه في الشمال
من دون الحديث عما يجري على الحدود
الشماليه وفي المسارات البحريه اشيل ايرز
بجيش اسرائيل ضابط يعترف بالالم ويعلن ان
جنازه عسكريه تقام كل خمس دقائق يعني
بالساعه 12 اتيل يشيعون الى مثواهم الاخير
في المقابر اليه
او المقابر
الدرزيه
5 لاحظتم كيف ان الحاخام واحد طلاب الحري
انزلا عن المنبر عندما بدا بالافصاح امام
الكاميرا عن ارقام المتساقطين في معارك
غزه يشتهر الجيش الاسرائيلي تاريخيا
بارتفاع معدلات الانتحار في صفوفه الان
تقدم المقاومه الفلسطينيه خدمه لليائسين
منهم ويقول العرض توجه فورا الى حي
الشجاعيه او الشجاعيه في غزه
وتقلاش حتما ستموت كما حل بمجموعه من لواء
جولاني كمنت لها
المقاومه حي الشجاعيه معقل حماس ووكر
الدبابير الاصعب والاخطر كما يسميه محللون
اسرائيليون تحول الى كابوس يلاحق ضباط
وجنود جولاني الذين خبروه سابقا في معركه
قاسيه عام
2014 ودفعوا حين ذاك ايضا ثمنا باهظا حي
الشجاعيه هو الحي نفسه الذي واجهت فيه
الكتيبه نفسها من لواء جولاني حادثا
مشابها عام
2014 شباب بعمر الورود كان يجب ان يكونوا
في بلادهم الاصليه يخططون لمستقبل جميل
بدل ان ياتوا الى فلسطين ليقتلوا الاطفال
فيقتلهم الرجال والد احد قتلى لواء جولاني
يعترف بان ابنه التحق بالجيش طفلا ليكون
شعار الجنديه لفن دوله اسرائيل من الفرات
للنيل من الفتا الى
الفناء
لطو
منشورات اسرائيليه تعرض مكافات ماليه لمن
يدلي بمعلومات عن قاده حماس في الوقت الذي
تتمنى فيه امهات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين تقديم المعلومات مجانا عن
نتنياهو ورفاقه لرجال المقاومه الفلسطينيه
الذين يقاتلون المحتله حفاه دفاعا عن تراب
الوطن معظم الاقوياء مغرورون وهناك درجه
على سلم الغرور لابد من السقوط عند بلوغها
نتنياهو يقول ان اهالي الجنود القتلى
اعطوه تفويضا بمحاربه الارهاب طبعا شو
بدهم بس ادهم يموتوا من الجيش اود ان اقرا
الرساله التي تلقيتها هذا الصباح من
العشرات من عائلات ابطالنا الذين سقطوا
كتبوا الشعب قووي وذو روح ثابته والمدنيون
ابطال وجنود عازمون على تحقيق النصر
المطلق لديك تفويض بالقتال وليس لديك
تفويض بالتوقف في المنتصف ماذا عن تفويض
اهالي الاسرى
الاسرائيليين والد احد المقتولين برصاص
جيشه يقول للدوا قتلتم ابني ومات موته
الكلاب ابني ومن معه خرجوا من المبنى في
وضح النهار رفعوا الاعلام البيض وصرخوا
طالبين المساعده وطلبوا ان ينقذوهم وبدلا
من ذلك اطلقوا عليهم النار بدم بارد ابني
قام بعمل بطولي لا يستحق ان يدفن ككلب
المستشرق اليهودي موردخاي كيدار يتوصل بعد
طول خبره الى الخلاصه التاليه الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقاتل لاجل الدنيا اما
المقاومه الفلسطينيه فتقاتل لاجل
الله
[موسيقى]
ز
هل هذا المستشرق رقيق المشاعر ليقول هذا
الكلام ابدا بل هو متوحش على
الفلسطينيين لكنه يمتدح ايمانهم ليهجو
الدفن هناك اسرائيليون يعني وصفوا
الفلسطينيين في غزه وصفوهم بانهم حيوانات
بل اقل من حيوانات انا انا لا اسويهم
بالحيوانات لان هذا تحقير للحيوانات
الحاخام عوزي شربف اطلق كلمات كالرصاص على
العلاقات مع مصر التي اعتبرها بصحراء
ونهرها جزءا من ارض اسرائيل
الكبرى المشكله الاكبر في ان هذا الزعم
موجود بنصوص
مدسه كما
يقول
خبل
بتخد هل هذا حاخام يغرد خارج السرب كلا
فبي بي نتنياهو يوافقه المعتقد الدينيه
وقد اكد ذلك اكثر من مره كذلك زعماء
وزعيما حركات الاستيطان اما وزير الدفاع
السابق اكدور لابرم فقد دع جيش الاحتلال
الى الاستعداد لحرب محتمله مع كل من مصر
والاردن سكان شمالي سيناء مستمرون في الم
بعت بقلق لمجريات الحرب الحديث لا يتوقف
عن خطط التهجير القصري للفلسطينيين لسيناء
الاسرائيليين لو طلعوهم من بلادهم مش
يرجعوهم تاني ما حدش بيسيب بلده معروفه ما
حدش بيسيب بلده هل عقيده الاباده المقدسه
عامه في اسرائيل اسفت مجنده اسرائيليه
انها لم تتمكن من قتل اكثر من فلسطينيين
اثنين في
غزه يجب ان تزور حي الشجاعي
الخبير العسكري الفرنسي الان كورفا يؤكد
ان طوفان الاقصى هو بدايه النهايه
لاسرائيل
ويكا حدد موعد
الدفن 23 كان رقم اخر اسيره اسرائيليه حتى
الان قتلها جيش الاحتلال خطا في غزه بعد
ثلاثه ارقام سبقتها علما ان دموع نتنياهو
على القتلى لا تمحو حبر بروتوكول هان بعل
السري الذي يسمح للاسرائيليين بقتل اسراهم
فالاسيكلوفير
اعرب عن اسفه لما وصفه بماساه لا تحتمل
وبهذا يرتفع عدد الرهائن الذين اكد الجيش
مقتلهم الى 22 من اصل نحو 250 شخصا وبعد
اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي مقتل الرهائن
الثلاثه خرجت احتجاجات في تل ابيب تحقيقات
جيش الاحتلال كشفت ان الاسرى الثلاثه
كانوا يرفعون علما او خلقه بيضاء وطلبوا
النجده مرارا باللغه العبريه وهذا يثبت
التزام المقاومه الاسلاميه بقانون عدم قتل
الاسرى في الاسلام كما يثبت التزام جنود
الاحتلال ببروتوكول هان بعل لاعدام اسراهم
ميدانيا ثم يقولون لك ان المسلمين واصحاب
اللحى والعمائم ارهابيون لا يحبون الحياه
سوف نبقى
هنا كي يزول
الالم
سوف نحيا
هنا سوف يحل
النم يستذكر مسؤول عسكري اسرائيلي رفيع ان
قائد حماس في غزه يحيى السنوار توعدهم
عندما كان في قبضتهم بان الادوار سيتم
تبادلها بين الاسر الاسرائيلي والاسير
الفلسطيني
ل
روايه الاعلامي الاسرائيل على ان حركه
حماس لا تم الفلسطينين
لكن الجيش لا يترك شابا في غزه دون
اعتقاله بتهمه الانتماء لحركه المقاومه
الاسلاميه الشباب الذين تقطم للتحقيق
عاديون الهيئه والملابس حتى ان سراويل
الجينز التي يلبسونها بعضها ساحل وكان
البعض يتندر على حماس بانها تمنعها على
اعضائها البدايه باكملها تحول ركام بعد
تدمير جيش الاحتلال لها الى شاهد قبر
جماعي قصري للاطفال ماس وعمر وعبد الله
الذين لم يحظوا بسنه اكرام الميت بعد ما
فحر وم لقوش ثلاث اطفال الله يرحمهم كتبوا
اساميهم على اساس
لقدام بسبب قله المعدات ولا لقوا حاجه ان
شاء الله يتذكروا انه في اطفال ل عمر عبد
الله وماس
طلوا تحت وان شاء الله لما يجي معدات او
توقف الحرب ان شاء الله يجوا يلاقوها
اسرائيل المتخصصه في اجترار اكذوبه
تحييدها المدنيين واتهامها المقاومه
بالتتر بهم ترصد السي اي اي استخدامها
المفرط للقنابل الغبيه التي يقول لها
قاذفها اقتلي حيث شئتي قنابل غبيه هي محور
تقييم جديد الاستخبارات الامريكيه ذكر ان
ما يقرب من نصف القنابل جو ارض التي
استخدمتها اسرائيل في حرب غزه كانت من هذا
النوع حسب تقرير نشرته شبكه سي ان ان
القنابل التي تعرف بالغب هي قنابل غير
موجهه وغير دقيقه وتشكل خطرا اكبر على
المدنيين وبخاصه في منطقه مكتظه بالسكان
مثل قطاع غزه وحسب الخبراء فانه اذا كانت
اسرائيل تستخدم قنابل غير موجهه بالمعدل
الذي تتوقعه الولايات المتحده فان ذلك
يقوض ادعاء اسرائيل بانها تحاول تقليل
الخسائر في صفوف
[موسيقى]
المدنيين قال تعالى ولنبلونكم بشيء من
الخوف والجوع ونقص من الاموال والانفس
والثمرات وبشر الصابرين عارف يعني ايه صبر
الصبر هو استمرارك على صفاتك الجميله رغم
تغير الاحداث من حواليك فالعطاء وقت
الوفره ده خلق الكرماء لكن العطاء وقت
الضيق خلق الاولياء الاحسان في الرخاء خلق
الاسوياء لكن الاحسان وقت الايذاء خلق
الانبياء الايه القرانيه الكريمه يشرحها
الصابرون في غزه والضفه بدرس علمي عملي
عالمي اسهم حتى الان في اسلام العديد من
الاج
a video of a woman holding her child
and her
child she was thanking god at that
moment and she saying allah akar and she
saying in arabic from you we came and to
you we will return and just thanking god
so much in that moment and i said i
don't think i could do that so i said i
need to read this book they talking
about the quran i need to read this and
see what is it that they believe in
i out as chran 25 years and lally the
first sentence i was just blown away
like i like it was speaking directly to
me عندما يجهر الجريح في غزه بالقران
الكريم فان صوته لا يقف عند حدود سياره
الاسعاف منهم من قضى نحبه ومنهم من
ينتظر وما بدلوا
تبديلا تعال تعال اخذت
[موسيقى]
اكل خلص غيره يلا غيره يلا غيره
الله ماما ال الول حصلي
ماما ال حط لي الولد ايه في على كؤوس شاي
بعد وليمه قاتله سال سياسي عربي حساس
زميله وهو ينفخ دخان السيجار الكوبي بحرقه
ترى هل سنسال يوم القيامه عن تركن اطفال
غزه يتضورون جوعا فالخليفة بن الخطاب رضي
الله عنه قال لو ماتت شاه على شط الفرات
ضائعه لظننت ان الله تعالى سائلي عنها يوم
القيامه ارتشف زميله العزيز بلعه شاي مقرف
بالقرفه واجاب صديقي سيدنا عمر تحدث عن
شاه وليس على علم ان الشات تجوع في غزه
سيذبح
وياكلون فضحاه ضحكا ضحك طفلين معا
وتشرد حتى خرج الشاي من المناخير لم يعرف
اهل غزه الجوع من قبل لكننا نقابل اشخاصا
لم ياكلوا منذ يومين او ثلاثه تصريح صادم
للمفوض العام لوكاله الاونور يسلط فيه
الضوء على كارثه انسانيه وشيكه في قطاع
غزه مع تفشي ازمه الجوع وسط القتال وصعوبه
توصيل المساعدات ناشط سياسي يميني لبناني
شق عن قلوب حماس ووجد ان ايران تتربع فيها
وليس فلسطين انا باعتقادي ما قامت به حماس
بكل صراحه وفي كثير ناس بدها تزعل مني ما
قامت به حماس هو خدمه للمشروع الايراني
وليس خدمه لمشروع الدوله الفلسطينيه
المستقله كمان ما تزعل نوفل ممن سيقول ان
كلامك ليس خدمه للمصالح الوطنيه بل هو
خدمه للاحتلال
الصهيوني
4000 دافني فرنسي اسرائيلي يشاركون في
مجازر اباده غزه ما حمل النائب الفرنسي
الحر توماس بورتس الى مطالبه حكومه بلاده
بادانه جرائم هؤلاء
الدوافه وحتى لا يشكك احد في كلامه ظهر
جنديان فرنسيان
دافني في رساله سخريه بالنائب المحترم من
قلب ميدان المعارك في
[موسيقى]
غزه انه ارهاب بهذه العباره ادان بابا
الفاتيكان فرانسيس مقتل امراتين مسيحيتين
لجات الى الكنيسه في غزه واعتبر ان
اسرائيل تستخدم اساليب الارهاب في قطاع
غزه ايها الدوافه في اسرائيل وحول العالم
تصرخ في وجوهكم فتاه امريكيه مسلمه انتم
تقتلون اطفالنا وتعتد على مقدساتنا ثم
تقولون اننا ارهابيون يا معشر الارهاب
والسباب
سمعون ركل صحفي اسرائيلي دافني متوحش عرض
على الهواء مشكلته الشخصيه التي تتعلق
بنومه قال انه لا يستطيع النوم دون ان
يشاهد بيوت عائلات غزه تنهار على الارض
فماذا يفعل ارشدو
بتعليقاتكم
نحن نعرف ان شيخ المحشي طبق سوري شهير
يمزج بين الخضار واللحوم والالبان لكننا
فجئنا هذا الاسبوع بظهور شيخ المحشي
الاصلي بل شيخ المحاشي الذي يخلط بين
الصحابه الكرام وعن تره ابن شداد طيب
غزه حكومه حماس اللي قامت في غزه هذه
حكومه خرجت عن العهد والميثاق اللي وقعته
الضفه الغربيه ومنظمه فتح المعترف بها
دوليا في اوسلو فيعتبر اهل حماس على هذه
النظره
ايش خوارج ناقضين ل يا حج اقرا جريده على
الاقل قبل ان تخبص في السياسه شيخ المحاشي
العزيز من عائله بازمول ويستهزئ باسم
عائله السنوار اطلع السنوار هذا يحيى
السنوار ما ادري السيوان مادري يجي يقول
يقول لسه احنا ما وريناك اللي عندنا
القيادي العباسي كما يوصف محمود الهباس
قرر مقاضاه الشهداء الذين اذهلوا اسرائيل
والعالم سيكون هناك حديث وحديث قاسي
ومحاسبه قاسيه ولكن ليس الان لا نريد الان
ان ناخذ في تفاصيل ولكن 100 الف انسان
قتلوا في قطاع غزه استشهدوا في قطاع غزه
او
جرحوا مئات الاف المباني المدمره والبنيه
التحتيه المدمره اقول لك بوضوح ولشعبنا
هذا لن يمر مرا عابرا ولا احد فوق النقد
ولا احد فوق المحاسبه وبمناسبه الاحتلال
ما بش ذرائع ولكنه ستفيد من الذرائع هل
يشاهد الهباش وحسين الشيخ جرائم اسرائيل
اليوميه في الضفه هناك جنود قد يحتاجون
الى نار للارجيله في جنين يعني في اطار
التنسيق
الامني
دمار وقتلى وجرحى فلسطينيون في جنين تلك
بعض من شهادات اهالي المخيم بعد التوغل
الاسرائيلي حيث يعاينون الاضرار التي طالت
المباني والممتلكات يقول نشطاء فلسطينيون
ان القوات الاسرائيليه شنت حمله دهم
واقتحامات واسعه شملت مدنا وبلدات عده
بالضفه يصف الاهالي الوضع في جينين بانه
اكثر صعوبه مما عاشوه خلال اجتياح في عام
2002 الزعيم الالماني النازي ادولف هيتلر
لا شك انه سفاح وقد افرغ حقدا مرعبا على
اليهود في المحرقه الهولوكوست لكن ليش عم
بتحاول اسرائيل تعمل له دعايه بعد 78 عاما
على
وفاته جنود الاحتلال يدنسون المساجد في
الضفه على مسمع ومرا من السلطه
الفلسطينيه
باحذيه داخل مسجد في مدينه جنين بالضفه
الغربيه المحتله انتشر على منصات التواصل
الاجتماعي هذا الفيديو لجنود اسرائيليين
وهم يرددون ويتلون عبر مكبرات الصوت صلوات
يهوديه تاييد خيار المقاومه لا يقتصر على
الفلسطينيين والعرب ولا حتى على المسلمين
الرياضي التركي نجم الدين اربكان اكيوز
الحائز على بطولتين اوروبين في الكونغ فو
[موسيقى]
festina l l lever
palestina lever palestina och grossa
sionis palestina och grossa sionis och
vi har rat jorden och vi har odat jorden
och vi har
skat och vi har
[موسيقى]
اخيرا اصبحت ثياب العيد عند الاطفال
المسلمين بدله ابو عبيده الداعيه
الموريتاني محمد الحسن الددو يحتفي بطفل
قاطع محاضرته وهو يتقمص شخصيه ابو عبيد
الناس بسره وجداه ويفيض العرفان ويفيض
العرفان اذا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اقل ختاما هل تفتح اسرائيل حربا موازيه
لمحرق في غزه على الصحفيين الفلسطين
ولا سما في شبكه الجزيره هل تعتقد انها
بقتلها شهيدنا سامر ابو دقه ستغيب الصوت
والصوره الا يضعون من صبر وائل الدحدوح
الذي اصبحت جروحه مدرسه في الصمود وقد
اختارته جريده صوت الازهر رجل العام ان
فجيعه عائلي وشعبي وزملاء الشهيد سامر ابو
دجه بفقدانه لا تقلل من فخرهم ببطولته
وبولا للحق
والحقيقه حتى الشهاده الى اللقاء مرحبا
انا اسمي زين ابن الغالي الشهيد سامر ابو
دقه اول شيء انا بحب اقول الله يرحمك يا
بابا ونشوفك ان شاء الله بنت جنه وان شاء
الله راح احقق حلمي اللي انت كنت بدك
اياني اوصله ان شاء الله راح اصير مغني
كبير والدنيا كلها تعرفني بحبك يا بابا
ياش قد
مشتاق عذبني
الفراس قلبي عادك ضا واللي مر يابا اداك
يابا غيابك وين وان توه في ال درب الالم
طويل وما ظل فييها ح ياباش قد
[موسيقى]
مشتاق
ه